Here's the kind of thing that changes you from one kind of person into another. Adam and Wendy had been looking for a house for years, which is what you have to do if you don't have a lot of money. And finally, they found this house that they liked. And the broker showed it to them before it came into the market, so the actually had a shot at getting the house. And then, they were completely ripped off, but ripped off in this way that seems almost calculated to get inside their very molecules and rip them off at the cellular level.
这就是那种让你从一种人变成另一种人的事情。亚当和温迪多年来一直在找房子，这是如果你没有很多钱时必须做的。最终，他们找到了这栋他们喜欢的房子。房产经纪人在房子上市前就向他们展示了它，所以他们实际上有机会买下这栋房子。然后，他们完全被坑了，但这种被坑的方式似乎经过精心计算，深入到他们的每一个分子，在细胞层面将他们洗劫一空。
The owners of the house, they were very warm and friendly with us, and--
房子的主人对我们非常热情友好，而且——
Paternal.
像长辈一样。
Paternal, they were very paternal. In fact, they reminded me of my parents in a way. They were an academic couple.
像长辈一样，他们非常像长辈。事实上，他们在某种程度上让我想起了我的父母。他们是一对学者夫妻。
She seemed like an old hippie, which made me feel like, I don't know, she's pretty genuine. She wore clogs and just seemed kind of cool, and long gray hair, and--
她看起来像个老嬉皮士，这让我觉得，我不知道，她挺真诚的。她穿着木屐，看起来很酷，留着灰色长发，而且——
They said to us at one point, "You know, we have great compassion for you two because we've got children your own age. And so we have great compassion for what you're doing."
有一次他们对我们说：“你们知道，我们非常同情你们两个，因为我们也有和你们年纪相仿的孩子。所以我们对你们正在做的事情深表同情。”
But it seemed really genuine at the time.
但当时这看起来真的很真诚。
An inspector came and pointed out a few problems with the house. For instance, the owners had said that the roof was brand new. But in fact, the inspector said, it had simply been painted silver and was a web of cracks and problems. The steps leading up to the house were being rebuilt, but the inspector said that the workmanship was no good. It would not last the winter.
一位验房师来了，指出了房子的一些问题。例如，房主曾说屋顶是全新的。但实际上，验房师说，它只是被刷成了银色，到处都是裂缝和问题。通往房子的台阶正在重建，但验房师说工艺不好，根本熬不过冬天。
And then there was the question of the abandoned house next door. What was going to happen there? They understood that they knew nothing about it, nothing at all. But might it affect the value of this house? The owners insisted on talking out the problems face-to-face.
还有隔壁那栋废弃房子的事。那儿会发生什么？他们声称对此一无所知，完全不知道。但这会影响这栋房子的价值吗？房主坚持要当面谈这些问题。
And they invited us over and gave us coffee. And we sat right in this room.
他们邀请我们过去，还给了我们咖啡。我们就坐在现在的这个房间里。
We sat right here. I think we sat in their couch, which was where our couch now is. And we looked them in the eye, and they sat across from us. And that's when I got the first sense that they were playing us.
我们就坐在这儿。我想我们当时坐在他们的沙发上，也就是我们现在放沙发的地方。我们直视他们的眼睛，他们坐在我们对面。就在那时，我第一次感觉到他们是在耍我们。
They didn't believe the inspector. They said, that's crazy, we have a new roof. And this guy that is doing the stoop is doing a very good job in fact.
他们不相信验房师。他们说，那太荒谬了，我们的屋顶是新的。而且这个修台阶的人事实上干得非常好。
They made the point that the roof wasn't leaking on them. Therefore, it was not, as far as they were concerned, a problem. Therefore, why should it really enter the negotiations?
他们强调说屋顶并没有漏水。因此，在他们看来，这就不是问题。所以，为什么要把它纳入谈判呢？
Negotiations went back and forth for weeks. Wendy and Adam barely got their way on anything. But they bought the house anyway because they knew that if they didn't, somebody else would. They move in. And then, the very first time that it rains, streams of brown water come pouring into the house.
谈判进行了好几个星期。温迪和亚当几乎什么都没谈成。但他们还是买了这栋房子，因为他们知道如果不买，别人就会买走。他们搬了进去。然后，第一次下雨时，一股股棕色的水就涌进了屋里。
So the water started dripping from there, where you can see the brown stains. Water was coming down here.
所以水开始从那里滴下来，你可以看到棕色的污渍。水就是从这里流下来的。
The wall was bubbling out with a big pocket of water inside, and the plaster was falling.
墙壁鼓起一个大水泡，里面的灰泥正在脱落。
I just felt totally defeated when I saw that water. I couldn't believe it, how they just kept saying, the roof is new, you guys are crazy. You're totally overreacting. You can't listen to contractors who tell you you need a new roof. Yeah, you need a new roof. Yeah, right. Well, we've never had this. This place has never-- we never had a leak.
看到那水的时候，我感到彻底崩溃了。我简直不敢相信，他们竟然一直说，屋顶是新的，你们疯了吧。你们反应过度了。你们不能听信那些告诉你们需要换屋顶的承包商的话。是啊，你需要换屋顶。是啊，没门。好吧，我们从来没遇到过这种情况。这个地方从来没——我们从来没漏过水。
And as soon as the water started, I started to really look at the ceiling. And I noticed that, wait a minute, you can see where it was leaking before. I had never noticed. It was very subtle, just a little bit of yellowing. And someone had repaired it. So they did lie to us.
水一漏，我就开始仔细观察天花板。我注意到，等一下，你可以看到它之前漏过的地方。我以前从没注意到。非常细微，只有一点点泛黄。有人修补过它。所以他们确实对我们撒了谎。
The second day they were in the house, Adam was walking up the steps to the front door, and he heard a sound, the steps cracking under his feet. Their first weekend in the house, they woke up to a different sound, the sound of jackhammers. It turns out that not only was there construction starting on the house next door, it would extend that house 15 feet back, blocking out all of the western sunlight from Adam and Wendy's backyard. And if that were not enough, neighbors informed them that the previous owners knew all about it, in fact, had led an organizing drive on the block to stop this construction.
他们住进房子的第二天，亚当走上台阶去前门，听到了一声响，那是台阶在他脚下开裂的声音。他们在房子里的第一个周末，被另一种声音吵醒了，是手提钻的声音。原来，隔壁不仅开始动工，还要将房子向后扩建15英尺，挡住了亚当和温迪后院所有的西向阳光。如果这还不够，邻居告诉他们，前房主对此一清二楚，事实上，他们还曾在街区组织过请愿活动来阻止这项施工。
And what makes the whole thing so galling is they're still living in the home of the people who took advantage of them. Every day, they're reminded of these people. They smell their smell in the closet. When the drains back up, it's their hair and grease.
最让人气愤的是，他们仍然住在那些占了他们便宜的人的房子里。每天，他们都会想起这些人。他们在壁橱里闻到他们的气味。当排水管堵塞时，那是他们的头发和油脂。
We've gone through the house, over all the surfaces with razor blades, scraping off the fingerprints and the dirt. And it's obsessive. We've gotten overly meticulous about it.
我们已经用剃须刀片刮遍了屋里的所有表面，刮掉了指纹和污垢。这是一种强迫行为。我们在这些方面变得过于细致了。
But every time I open those doors over there, I think of them. I think of their greasy hands, every time, even though I have scrubbed. In fact, over here, you can see I became really crazy, and I started scrubbing these cabinets. And I actually got the finish off of it, I was scrubbing so hard.
但每次我打开那边的门，我就会想到他们。我就会想到他们油腻的手，即使我已经刷洗过了。事实上，在这边，你可以看到我变得很疯狂，我开始擦洗这些橱柜。我擦得太用力，竟然把漆面都刷掉了。
Now, Wendy and Adam, I should say, are the sort of do-gooders who, when they move out of an apartment they've been renting, they'll hire a cleaner to make sure that the place is spotless for the next tenants. When they sell a car, they get that extra brake job for $600 before putting it on the market, not because they necessarily think it'll get a better price, and usually it does not, but because they think that it is right. They believe in deals where everybody walks away feeling like the deal was fair. Or anyway, that's the kind of people they used to be before they bought a house.
现在，我得说，温迪和亚当属于那种好好先生，当他们从租住的公寓搬走时，会请清洁工确保房子对下一任租客来说一尘不染。当他们卖车时，会在上市前多花600美元去换刹车片，不是因为他们觉得这样能卖出更好的价钱（通常也不会），而是因为他们觉得这样做才是对的。他们相信那种双方都能对交易感到公平的交易。或者说，在买这栋房子之前，他们是那种人。
That's changed the way I deal with people now. I'm bitter about it. I don't trust anyone anymore.
现在，这改变了我对待他人的方式。我对此感到愤恨。我再也不信任任何人了。
In every negotiation, the way you see it now is, somebody's going to be the sucker.
在每一次谈判中，你现在的看法就是，总有人会当冤大头。
Yeah, I feel that way now. I feel that there's a winner and a loser.
是的，我现在有这种感觉。我觉得世界上有赢家和输家。
That you're either going to get screwed by somebody, or you're screwing somebody.
要么就是你被别人坑，要么就是你坑别人。
Just last weekend, they went to a big home supplies hardware chain, a chain where they have gotten terrible advice in the past, terrible service. They needed some bolts. And, filled with anger and a spirit of vengeance, they simply stole them. The opportunity presented itself. They took advantage.
就在上周末，他们去了一家大型家居五金连锁店，一家他们过去曾获得过糟糕建议、体验过糟糕服务的连锁店。他们需要一些螺栓。心中充满了愤怒和报复心理，他们直接把螺栓偷走了。机会摆在眼前。他们利用了它。
And my friend, it felt good to steal. It felt good to make somebody else the sucker. They think they're going to do it again. That is what they have learned from the previous owners of their house.
我的朋友，偷窃的感觉真好。让别人当冤大头的感觉真好。他们认为他们还会再干一次。这就是他们从这栋房子的前房主那里学到的。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it is This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. Today on our program, Suckers. There are some people who see the world as a place where everybody can work out their differences and come to settlements, where everybody is happy, everybody getting along. And there are people who believe it's eat or be eaten, screw or be screwed. Today, the chasm that divides those two worldviews.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。今天我们节目的主题是：冤大头。有些人认为世界是一个大家可以解决分歧、达成和解、人人快乐、和睦相处的地方。还有些人认为这是一个弱肉强食、要么坑人要么被坑的世界。今天，我们要探讨分隔这两种世界观的鸿沟。
They both can't be right. Either the world is dog-eat-dog or not. Today, we try to figure out which it is. Stay with us.
它们不可能都对。世界要么是弱肉强食的，要么不是。今天，我们试图找出真相。请继续收听。
Act One, No Receipt, No Surrender. Perhaps you're familiar with the story of a certain New Jersey family. They live in a lovely suburban home. The neighbors have no idea how all the nice stuff they own arrives there, or if they suspect, they keep their mouths shut. The attitude of the head of the household, sometimes there are opportunities to take, and you take them. Or maybe you don't know the family I'm talking about.
第一幕：没收据，不退让。也许你听说过新泽西州某个家庭的故事。他们住在一个漂亮的郊区住宅里。邻居们不知道他们拥有的那些好东西是怎么来的，即使他们有所怀疑，也会守口如瓶。这家之主的态度是，有时有些机会可以把握，你就去把握。又或者，你不知道我说的是哪一家。
I wouldn't even call it a crime. People do it all the time.
我甚至不会称之为犯罪。人们经常这么做。
This is a woman who asked to be identified only by her first name, Sheila, for reasons that will become all too clear to you. I should say that she does not make a living off of her little random opportunities. Her husband is a doctor, and he supports the family. But she embodies the kind of worldview that we're talking about in this week's show.
这位女士要求只以她的名字“希拉”来称呼，原因你很快就会明白。我应该说，她并不是靠这些随机的小机会为生。她丈夫是位医生，支撑着这个家庭。但她体现了我们这期节目要探讨的那种世界观。
She's the sort of person who talks hotels into giving her discounts when, really, they have no reason to, who shows up at famous restaurants where she has no reservation, sneaks a look at the names in the reservation book, and then claims to be one of the people listed in order to be seated right away. She's talked her way into sold-out events. She's talked her way into the Getty Museum. Here's a typical scam.
她是那种能说服酒店给她折扣的人，尽管他们根本没理由这么做；是那种在没有预订的情况下出现在著名餐厅，偷偷看一眼预订簿上的名字，然后冒充其中一人以求立刻入座的人。她曾凭三寸不烂之舌进入售罄的活动现场。她还曾凭此进入盖蒂博物馆。这是她典型的骗术之一。
I had been shopping with my older daughter. And I insisted that she buy this most gorgeous Geoffrey Beene outfit that had the Saks Fifth Avenue hangtag price of, I think, $3,800. And at Loehmann's, it was, oh, about $200. And I said, "Oh, Susan, you really have to have this."
我和大女儿去购物。我坚持让她买了这套最华丽的杰弗里·比恩套装，我记得萨克斯第五大道百货的吊牌价是3800美元。在Loehmann's百货店，价格大概是200美元。我说：“哦，苏珊，你一定要买下这件。”
OK, well, she took it, and, of course, as luck would have it, she never put it on her back. About a year or so later, I said to my husband, "Would you mind detouring into the city, and we'll go to the Geoffrey Beene boutique at Saks?" And he said, OK. He doesn't generally approve of things like this, but I really didn't tell him what the purpose was.
好吧，她拿下了它，当然，正如运气所致，她从来没穿过。大约一年左右后，我对丈夫说：“你不介意绕道进城，我们去萨克斯的杰弗里·比恩专卖店吧？”他说，好吧。他通常不赞成这样的事情，但我真的没告诉他目的是什么。
So I took the garment upstairs to the boutique, and I spoke to the buyer, told them that this had been purchased at another Saks, and I would like to return it. And he said, "That's not a problem." And he looked at the hangtag, and he said, "Well, the item has been marked down. It's now, I think, about $2,200."
于是我把衣服带到楼上的精品店，告诉买手这件衣服是在另一家萨克斯买的，我想退货。他说：“没问题。”他看了看吊牌，说：“嗯，这件商品已经降价了。我想现在大概是2200美元。”
No longer $3,800.
不再是3800美元了。
Right. I said, "Well, that's all right. Just credit my account."
对。我说：“嗯，那没关系。就把钱退到我账户里吧。”
That was a $2,000 profit. You paid $200 for it at Loehmann's.
那可是2000美元的利润。你在Loehmann's才花了200美元。
Right, right, right.
对，对，对。
Now, your daughter Jen is sitting in the studio with you. Jen, do you just want to give your perspective on this, what this was like growing up with this happening all the time?
现在，你女儿珍和你一起在演播室里。珍，你想分享一下你的看法吗？从小到大一直经历这些是什么感觉？
I knew from a very young age that my mother wasn't necessarily like other mothers. My mother had a very large Country Squire station wagon when I was growing up. And oftentimes, the back of the car would be filled with things that were not illegally gotten, but certainly questionably gotten.
我很小的时候就知道我妈妈和其他妈妈不一定一样。我长大时，妈妈有一辆很大的乡村绅士旅行车。通常，车后座堆满了并不是通过合法渠道，但肯定是通过可疑渠道得来的东西。
I remember very clearly when I was very young, there was a promotion at a bank. And if you opened a checking account, you could get, I think, one blender or one toaster, one of something. But my mother thought, well, why get one, when I could open multiple checking accounts and get a whole bunch of them?
我清楚地记得我很小的时候，有一家银行搞促销。如果你开一个支票账户，可以得到，我想，一个搅拌机或一个烤面包机，或者别的东西。但我妈妈想，既然我可以开多个支票账户并拿到一堆，为什么要拿一个呢？
And I remember returning to our house, I must have been maybe five or six, with the trunk filled with these blenders or toasters. And we already had a blender and a toaster. We didn't need multiples. But my mother has built this warehouse in our basement where she literally outfitted the homes of all of my cousins, who are all older than I am. I don't think anybody bought anything off the shelf.
我记得回到家时，我大概才五六岁，后备箱里装满了这些搅拌机或烤面包机。我们已经有一个搅拌机和一个烤面包机了。我们不需要那么多。但我妈妈在地下室建了一个仓库，她真的把所有堂兄弟姐妹的家都装备齐了，他们都比我大。我不认为有谁是从商店买过东西的。
How often will you do something like this? Will you have something like this going, say, once a week or so?
你多久会做一次这样的事？比如说，一周左右会有一次这样的情况吗？
Oh, no.
哦，不。
Mom?
妈妈？
No, a few times during the year.
不，一年也就几次。
Mom, I would say, conservatively, 24 times a year, you've got some scam running.
妈妈，我觉得保守估计，你一年大概有24次在搞这种把戏。
What else has your mom done that you could never see yourself doing, when it comes to these kinds of things?
关于这些事情，你妈妈还做过什么你觉得自己永远不会做的事？
Oh, boy.
哦，天哪。
The Getty.
盖蒂博物馆。
Yeah, the Getty was a big one. My mother and I were at a wedding in California, in Los Angeles, and my mother very much wanted to go to the Getty. And I was keen on going to the Getty, but knew that you have two options. You either make a reservation months in advance to get a parking space, or you park at the bottom of a hill and take a bus up, which seems to me not the worst thing in the world. But my mother says to the attendant, we're on the list. We're staying at the Bel Air, and I believe the concierge made a reservation. I should be on the list. We have a parking space.
对，盖蒂那次是个大手笔。我和妈妈在加州洛杉矶参加婚礼，我妈妈非常想去盖蒂中心。我也很想去，但我知道你有两个选择。你要么提前几个月预约以获得停车位，要么停在山脚下坐公车上去，在我看来这也不是什么大不了的事。但我妈妈对管理员说，我们在名单上。我们住在贝莱尔酒店，我相信礼宾部做了预约。我应该在名单上。我们有停车位。
And clearly, we have not made a reservation. I know we have not made a reservation. And I am livid. And we drive in, and that was a very tense moment.
显然，我们根本没预约。我知道我们没预约。我气疯了。我们开车进去，那一刻非常紧张。
And then, what are you saying to him to--
然后，你是怎么对他说的——
Oh, but it's not possible. These reservations were made six months ago. I would not just show up here without a reservation. Do I look like that kind of a person?
哦，但这是不可能的。这些预约是六个月前做的。我不会就这样在没预约的情况下跑过来。我看起来像那种人吗？
With me rolling my eyes next to her. How he didn't see that and know that this was a scam, I have no idea.
当时我在她旁边翻着白眼。他怎么没看出来这是一场骗局，我真不知道。
I happen to look like a very honorable, decent sort of a person. But I have found a way to get around the system, which many people are reluctant to do.
我碰巧看起来像是一个非常高尚、正派的人。但我已经找到了一种绕过系统的方法，这是许多人不愿意做的。
And will you just keep going until they give you what you want? Or will you stop at some point?
你会一直纠缠直到他们给你想要的东西吗？还是会在某个时候停下来？
Yes, I am very tenacious.
是的，我非常执着。
And so your method is you just don't stop.
所以你的方法就是不停下来。
Right, because I won't take no for an answer. I just wear the person down, I suppose. And very often, it doesn't take very long.
对，因为我不接受“不”作为答案。我想我只是把对方磨垮了。通常情况下，这花不了多长时间。
For you, it's not about the money. It's just that it's like a sport for you, right?
对你来说，这根本不是钱的问题。这更像是一项运动，对吧？
It definitely is. It certainly is not about the money. My dad was a very successful executive. And he always said to me, if you walk into a place and hold your head up high, nobody will ever question because you look as though you belong where you are. And that has served me in good stead. Wherever I have wanted to get into, I have been successful in getting in.
绝对是。当然绝对不是为了钱。我爸爸是一位非常成功的经理人。他总是对我说，如果你走进一个地方，昂首挺胸，没人会质疑你，因为你看上去就属于那里。这对我很有帮助。无论我想去哪里，我都能成功进入。
Jen, do you sort of go too far in the other direction?
珍，你是不是在另一个方向走得太远了？
Yeah, absolutely. Like I'll pay double.
是的，绝对是。比如我会付双倍的钱。
You'll pay double.
你会付双倍的钱。
If something's going on sale tomorrow, that's OK. You know what? I'll pay what it costs today. It's fine. Don't worry about it. I always overtip. Yeah.
如果明天有什么东西打折，那没关系。你知道吗？我愿意付今天的原价。没关系。别担心。我总是给很多小费。是的。
I can't tell, hearing you talk about this, do you wish you were more like your mom?
听你这么说，我看不出来，你希望自己更像你妈妈吗？
In a lot of ways, I really do. Because she's fearless. And sometimes I think, like when I'm working, if I had my mother's steel stomach, I would probably be much better at what I do. Or conversely, she would be really good at what I do. But I just don't have it in me.
在很多方面，我真的希望。因为她无所畏惧。有时我想，比如我在工作时，如果我有我妈妈那样的铁石心肠，我可能会做得更好。或者反过来，她会很擅长我的工作。但我身上没有那种特质。
Well, after our interview, since Jen said that she wished that she were more like her mom, we got the idea to have Jen's mom give her a little lesson, a training exercise in being her. Here it is. Here's Jen.
好吧，在我们的采访之后，既然珍说她希望自己更像妈妈，我们就想到了让珍的妈妈给她上一课，做一个关于“如何成为她”的训练练习。就在这儿。这是珍。
We decided to try something simple. My assignment was to return a bright yellow sweater my boyfriend had received as a gift four years ago. It was from a high-end clothing store called Burberry. It was the type of sweater that might have been appropriate on a public golf course in Scotland in the mid-'80s. Suffice it to say, I hated the sweater.
我们决定尝试一些简单的东西。我的任务是退掉我男朋友四年前收到的一件亮黄色毛衣。那是从一家叫博柏利的高端服装店买的。那种毛衣大概在80年代中期苏格兰的公共高尔夫球场上穿还合适。足以说明，我讨厌这件毛衣。
This is what we had working for us. The sweater had originally been purchased at Burberry and had a Burberry label. There was even paper folded into the sweater, printed with the trademark logo. On the downside, we had no receipt and no hangtag. And of course, the sweater was four years out of fashion and looked it, none of which fazed my mother.
这就是我们手里有的筹码。这件毛衣最初确实是在博柏利买的，有博柏利的标签。毛衣里甚至还折着一张印有商标的纸。不利的一面是，我们没有收据，也没有吊牌。当然，这件毛衣已经过时四年了，看起来就很老旧，但我妈对此一点都不在意。
In fact, she thought the whole thing so easy, she decided to up the ante. She wanted me to try for a cash refund instead of a store credit. She was going to show me how.
事实上，她觉得整件事太简单了，决定增加赌注。她要我尝试退回现金而不是商店抵用券。她要展示给我看怎么做。
I don't have your skill, I don't know.
我没有你的技能，我不知道。
I would have preferred the raincoat.
我本来更想要那件雨衣的。
My mom showed up at my office wearing a crisply pressed blouse, gigantic Jackie O sunglasses, and a pair of knockoff Burberry plaid pants that simultaneously embodied her two biggest beliefs in life. Always dress the part, and never pay full price. The training session started with some role-playing.
我妈出现在我的办公室，穿着一件挺括的衬衫，戴着巨大的杰奎琳·肯尼迪式的太阳镜，还有一条仿制的博柏利格子裤，同时体现了她一生中最大的两个信念。永远穿着得体，永远不要全价购买。训练课程从角色扮演开始。
OK, so I'll be me, and you'll be the Burberry's manager. Hi, I have this sweater that my boyfriend got as a gift a couple of years ago.
好吧，我演我，你演博柏利的经理。嗨，我这儿有一件我男朋友几年前收到的礼物。
I don't know that I would say a couple of years ago. I wouldn't say when it was purchased. Play dumb. He just gave it to you because you were going to be in New York and asked that you return it.
我不认为我会说“几年以前”。我不会说它是什么时候买的。装傻。他只是把它给了你，因为你要去纽约，并要求你退掉它。
OK, so we'll start over again. Hi, I'd like to return this sweater.
好的，我们重来。嗨，我想退掉这件毛衣。
That's good. That's good. I like that. Yes, my dear, how can I help you?
那很好。那很好。我喜欢这个。是的，亲爱的，我有什么能帮你的吗？
This isn't the way my mother usually works. She believes in pure improv. But for my benefit, she concocts a backstory for me. It's astonishingly complicated.
这不是我妈妈通常的工作方式。她相信纯粹的即兴发挥。但为了我的利益，她编造了一个非常复杂的背景故事。
Apparently, I live in Arkansas with my Arkansas businessman boyfriend, who got this sweater as a gift, along with a lot of other Burberry clothing. Anyone who knows him knows it's his favorite store. I'm only in town for a day, and I rarely come to New York, so I want cash, not credit. And by the way, I don't know when the sweater was purchased, but he received it recently. It's such a crazy collection of facts that I have a hard time keeping it all straight.
显然，我住在阿肯色州，有一个阿肯色州的商人男朋友，他把这件毛衣作为礼物收下，还有很多其他的博柏利服装。认识他的人都知道这是他最喜欢的商店。我只是进城一天，很少来纽约，所以我想要现金，而不是抵用券。顺便说一句，我不知道这件毛衣是什么时候买的，但他最近才收到。这些事实组合在一起简直太疯狂了，我很难理清头绪。
OK, so from the top, here's what I'm remembering. I live in Arkansas. My boyfriend lives in Arkansas. He's in business in Arkansas. He doesn't travel to New York. I understand that it's--
好的，从头开始，我记住的是：我住在阿肯色州。我男朋友住在阿肯色州。他在阿肯色州做生意。他不往返于纽约。我理解这——
Has no occasion. Has no occasion.
“没有机会”。他没有机会（来纽约）。
What's the importance of the phrase "has no occasion"?
“没有机会”这个短语的重要性是什么？
Because it makes him sound like maybe he is a more important kind of a person, rather than some yokel. Make him sound like he's a CEO of some major company, but likes small town living and does not like the city and doesn't feel comfortable--
因为这让他听起来像是一个更有身份的人，而不是什么乡巴佬。让他听起来像是某个大公司的首席执行官，但喜欢小镇生活，不喜欢大城市，也不觉得自在——
This is method scamming. We head over to Burberry's. I'm wearing a hidden microphone, and my stomach immediately starts to hurt.
这就是专业诈骗。我们前往博柏利。我戴着隐形麦克风，胃立刻开始疼起来。
OK, so I'm from Arkansas, and I'm only visiting.
好的，我来自阿肯色州，我只是来旅游的。
Burberry is a sleek, luxe store filled with coiffed salespeople and stylish Japanese tourists. There's plenty of taupe cashmere muffling the sound system. Everything is ordered, serene. I'm directed to the manager.
博柏利是一家光鲜亮丽的精品店，到处是打理得一丝不苟的销售人员和时髦的日本游客。大量的灰褐色羊绒毯隔绝了音响系统的声音。一切都有条不紊、静谧优雅。我被引向了经理。
I have a sweater that my boyfriend received as a gift. And we live out of state. And he asked me to return it while I'm in New York.
我有一件我男朋友收到的礼物毛衣。我们住在外地。他让我趁在纽约的时候把它退掉。
The manager barely glances at me as he informs me of their policy. No receipt, no returns, no exceptions. I muster up the courage to try again and instantly forget every lesson my mother taught me. I volunteer information. I say things that could be used against me. I can't keep the facts of my fake story straight.
经理几乎没看我一眼，就告知了他们的政策。没收据，不退货，无一例外。我鼓起勇气再试一次，却立刻忘记了我妈妈教我的每一课。我主动提供了信息。我说了一些可能会被用来对付我的话。我无法理清那个虚假故事的事实。
It's possible it was purchased a little while ago. I don't have a receipt. And I'm actually not even sure who he got it from. So I'm not-- yeah, I have no idea to tell you the truth. He got a whole bunch of presents. I don't know.
它可能是前一阵子买的。我没有收据。老实说，我甚至不确定他从谁手里得到的。所以我不是——是的，说实话我一点头绪都没有。他收了一大堆礼物。我不知道。
All I want to do is get out of there. The guy is, after all, just doing his job. No receipt, no returns, no exception. I nod feebly and wonder why we don't just give the sweater to Goodwill.
我只想尽快离开那里。毕竟，那个人只是在做他的工作。没收据，不退货，无一例外。我无力地点点头，心想为什么我们不直接把毛衣捐给慈善机构算了。
I can feel that it's killing my mom to see me struggle like this, but she's trying to hold back. Finally the manager says, look, for all he knows, the sweater wasn't even bought at this store. It could have just come from some outlet. And that does it. My mom, unable to contain herself any longer, steps in.
我能感觉到我妈妈看到我这样挣扎简直要崩溃了，但她试图忍住。最后经理说，看，据他所知，这件毛衣甚至可能不是在这家店买的。它可能只是来自某个奥特莱斯。这下触动了开关。我妈再也忍不下去了，插话道。
Oh, I can assure you that this was not purchased at an outlet. I don't know about outlets, because I'm not an outlet shopper.
哦，我可以向你保证，这绝对不是在奥特莱斯买的。我不知道奥特莱斯，因为我不是奥特莱斯的购物者。
My mom saying she's not an outlet shopper is like saying she's not an air breather. My mom spends all of five minutes dealing with the manager before deciding it's a waste of time. Her cardinal rule is if you want something done right, you have to go straight to the top. Positioning herself firmly in front of the store's only cash register, she pulls out her cell phone and calls Burberry corporate headquarters.
我妈说她不是奥特莱斯购物者，就像说她不呼吸空气一样。我妈花了整整五分钟应付经理，然后决定这是浪费时间。她的至理名言是，如果你想把事情办好，就必须直接找最高层。她坚定地站在商店唯一的收银台前，掏出手机给博柏利的公司总部打电话。
Hi. I'm sorry to bother you. I'm trying to help my daughter's boyfriend.
嗨。很抱歉打扰你。我想帮助我女儿的男朋友。
I want to climb into the revolving rack of raincoats and disappear.
我想爬进雨衣的旋转货架里消失。
And then when he heard that my daughter was coming to New York, he asked her to bring it back to any one of the Burberry stores.
然后当他听说我女儿要来纽约时，他让她把这件东西带到任何一家博柏利店。
The lies fell from her like notes in an improvisational jazz saxophone solo. She's on a tear, and she will stop at nothing.
谎言像即兴萨克斯独奏中的音符一样从她嘴里流出。她火力全开，绝不退缩。
No, he received a whole bunch of gifts from Burberry. It happens to be his favorite store. And your manager can tell you that I'm wearing one of your pairs of pants today coincidentally.
不，他收到了一大堆博柏利礼物。碰巧这是他最喜欢的店。你的经理可以告诉你，我今天正好穿的就是你们的裤子。
Also coincidentally, people are starting to clear away from us. I'm sure the only thing the manager would attest to at this point is that he wants me, my mother, and her fake, Burberry, plaid pants the hell out of there.
同样凑巧的是，人们开始远离我们。我相信此时经理唯一能证明的就是，他希望我、我妈妈和她那条虚假的博柏利格子裤赶紧滚蛋。
Well, he's in Arkansas. I'm here in New York with the sweater. You know, there is a time difference between here and Arkansas.
嗯，他在阿肯色州。我带着毛衣在纽约。你知道，这里和阿肯色州有时差。
It's 12:00 in New York, which makes it 11:00 in Arkansas.
纽约是12点，阿肯色州是11点。
Well, I have been in many situations in my life, from Chanel to Givenchy, and I have never had a situation like this. I am a faithful Burberry shopper. Well, because I'm leaving the city today. I'm going out of state. And I probably won't be back for another year, so I was hoping--
嗯，我一生中经历过很多情况，从香奈儿到纪梵希，我从没遇到过这样的情况。我是博柏利的忠实顾客。嗯，因为我今天就要离开这座城市了。我要去外州。我大概一年内都不会再回来了，所以我希望能——
She's on the phone for over 20 minutes. Burberry's return policy is designed precisely with people like my mother in mind. They just keep repeating over and over, no receipt, no returns, no exceptions. At this point, I'm surprised to find that I'm getting mad. The nerve of them. After an hour and a half, we finally leave, defeated.
她在电话上打了20多分钟。博柏利的退货政策正是为我妈妈这样的人设计的。他们只是不断地重复，没收据，不退货，无一例外。此时，我惊讶地发现我竟然生气了。他们胆子真大。一个半小时后，我们终于离开了，失败而归。
I think you did really well, Mom. I couldn't have-- I gave up. I was dying inside. I was definitely like, oh, God. Just get us out of here. I don't want this mean man looking at me like this anymore. I feel ridiculous. I don't know what-- I'm trying to feel what a person from Arkansas would be feeling. I'm no help at all.
我觉得你做得很好，妈妈。我无法——我放弃了。我内心在受折磨。我当时肯定在想，哦，天哪。快带我们离开这儿。我不希望这个刻薄的人再这样看着我了。我觉得自己太荒唐了。我不知道什么——我正努力感受一个阿肯色州的人会是什么心情。我一点帮不上忙。
I really think that since everything jived, the label-- they didn't have a hangtag. Well, maybe that's the way they wrap their gifts, without a hangtag.
我真的认为既然一切都对上了，标签——他们没吊牌。嗯，也许他们送礼就是这样，不带吊牌。
Hear that? That's why I think my mom is so good at this. She truly believed she was in the right. She was actually furious at Burberry for not falling for her lies. She tells me this is unheard of. They've just lost a valuable customer. Never mind that she was never an actual customer in the first place. Later, back at the office, she chalks up our failure to one small strategic mistake.
听到了吗？这就是为什么我觉得我妈这么擅长此道。她真的相信她是正义的一方。她实际上对博柏利没掉进她的谎言陷阱感到愤怒。她告诉我这闻所未闻。他们刚刚失去了一位尊贵的顾客。别管她其实根本就不是什么顾客。后来，回到办公室，她把我们的失败归结为一个小小的战略失误。
The reason we didn't get satisfaction is because he knew that my pants were knockoffs.
我们没能得到满意的结果是因为他知道我的裤子是仿制品。
I think so too. I think you pushed it there. I think that's where we lost our credibility. It was a good try, Mom. It was a good effort.
我也这么认为。我觉得你在那一点上推得太过了。我认为那就是我们失去可信度的地方。是个很好的尝试，妈妈。已经是很努力了。
What started as a lark for me, a little mother-daughter bonding time, escalated far beyond that for her. It was now a question of honor. She shot off letters to the CEO, the CFO, and, to leave no stone unturned, the mayor of New York. She refused to read these letters to me, and I'm terrified to imagine what she said.
对我来说，这最初只是一场恶作剧，一点母女联络感情的时间，但对她来说，这远不止于此。这现在成了一个荣誉问题。她给首席执行官、首席财务官发去了信件，为了不遗漏任何细节，甚至还给纽约市长写了信。她拒绝把这些信读给我听，我害怕想象她说了些什么。
They must have been some letters though. The salesman called a week later to say that they were still working on the return. He called a few days after that to tell her that there was a credit waiting for her in the Spring Street store. They credited us for $59, which was brilliant on their part, because they paid less than the sweater was worth while getting my mother out of their hair forever. Honestly, if they paid her a dollar, she'd have declared victory.
那些信一定很厉害。一周后，销售员打来电话说他们还在处理退货事宜。几天后他又打来电话告诉她，弹簧街店里有一笔退款在等着她。他们给了我们59美元的抵用金，这对他们来说很聪明，因为他们支付的金额比毛衣本身的价值还要低，同时也让我妈妈永远离开了他们的视线。老实说，如果他们只给她一美元，她也会宣布胜利的。
The problem now is I can't go get the credit, because I'm supposed to be in Arkansas. Not only that, but the store is just three blocks from my job. I'm so afraid they'll recognize me, I try to avoid their street completely. When I can't, I cross the street, so they won't see me. I know my mom wouldn't hesitate to stroll right by.
现在的问题是我没法去取这笔退款，因为我应该在阿肯色州。不仅如此，这家店离我的工作地点只有三个街区远。我太害怕他们认出我了，我尽量完全避开那条街。实在没办法的时候，我就过马路，这样他们就看不见我了。我知道我妈会毫不犹豫地在那儿大摇大摆地走过。
Act Two, The Stereo Type. The sucker worldview is that when an opportunity presents itself, you and I should grab that opportunity. And if we do not, we are suckers.
第二幕：刻板印象。冤大头世界观认为，当机会出现时，你我都应该抓住。如果我们不抓住，我们就是冤大头。
Unfortunately, this mentality could also lead us to become big suckers because, of course, there is no better mark than somebody who thinks that he is about to beat the system. There's no bigger sucker than somebody who thinks that he is about to make someone else into a sucker. Well, with that in mind, we have this little fable about suckerdom from our producer, Alex Blumberg.
不幸的是，这种心态也可能导致我们成为真正的大冤大头，因为当然，没有什么比认为自己即将打败系统的人更好的目标了。没有什么比认为自己即将让别人成为冤大头的人更大的冤大头了。好吧，考虑到这一点，我们有一个关于冤大头的小寓言，来自我们的制作人亚历克斯·布隆伯格。
My friend Shane has this story about being a sucker and then getting the chance to get revenge on the people who suckered him. It starts when he was just 23. He had gotten one of his first adult paychecks, which seemed huge at the time. He was wearing a new suit that he'd bought with the money. He was walking down the street, thinking, this adult life is a breeze. Never before or since did he feel that the world was such a benevolent and bountiful place.
我的朋友肖恩有一个关于他自己如何成为冤大头，然后有机会报复那些坑他的人的故事。故事开始于他23岁的时候。他拿到了第一份成年人的工资，在那时看来数额巨大。他穿着那笔钱买的新西装。他走在街上，心想，这成年生活真是轻松。在此之前，他从未感到世界是一个如此慷慨和富足的地方。
And I'm approached by a van full of young guys in their, say, 20s. And it's got a stencil on the side. And they approach me, and they're like, "Hey, buddy. You want to buy some speakers?" And these guys really have it together. They're in uniforms. They have their names on the thing. The van is stenciled with the name of some company.
然后，一辆坐满20多岁年轻人的面包车向我靠近。车身上有喷漆模板印的字。他们靠近我，说：“嘿，伙计。你想买些扬声器吗？”这些人真的很专业。他们穿着制服，上面印着名字。面包车上也印着某家公司的名字。
And these aren't speakers that they've just pulled out of someone's living room, and the wires are dangling. They're boxed. They're packaged. They have shipping invoices. They have a whole clipboard full of delivery sites and inventory and this.
这些扬声器可不是那种刚从别人客厅里拔出来、电线还在晃荡的东西。它们有盒子，有包装。它们有运输发票。他们有一个装满送货地点、库存清单的剪贴板。
And they have this whole spiel. And the spiel is, "Dude, you know, we're, like, the delivery guys. And the dudes at the loading dock put too many speakers on the truck. And if we get rid of these before we get back, nobody knows, dude. Dude, we're just trying to unload these fast." And then it's like, "These are $1,200 speakers. We'll give them to you for five bills, buddy."
他们还有一整套说辞。说辞是，“哥们儿，你知道，我们是送货员。装卸台上的家伙装车装多了。如果我们在回去之前把这些处理掉，没人会知道的，伙计。伙计，我们只是想快点把它们卸下来。”然后接着说，“这是1200美元的音箱。500美元给你，哥们儿。”
Shane played along, acted like he's down, he's been through this before, he's one of them.
肖恩配合着演戏，装作他很懂，他经历过这些，他是他们的一员。
We're all dudes. We all know, we all speak that language. So I say, "Well, I want to hear them." So at this point, I'm just out of college, about two, three months. And I am living at my mother's house. And we're pretty far away from there. She lives in the suburbs. We're in the city. So I say, "Well, if you want to follow me, we can go try them out." And they're like, "All right."
大家都是哥们儿。我们都知道，我们都说那种语言。所以我说，“好吧，我想听听它们。”那时我刚大学毕业，大概两三个月。我住在母亲家里。离那儿很远。她住在郊区。我们在城里。所以我说，“好吧，如果你们想跟我走，我们可以去试试。”他们说，“好的。”
And so they follow me all the way back to my mother's house, which is a significant drive. And I get to my mom's house. And I'm looking at their setup, because I'm trying to think, can I plug the speakers in here to listen? And I can't. There's not enough wire to take it out of the wall.
于是他们一路跟到我妈妈家，那是一段不短的车程。到了我妈妈家。我看着他们的设备，因为我在想，我能在这里插上插头听听吗？但我不能。没有足够的线能把它从墙上接出来。
They follow me to the audio store. And I buy some speaker wire. And we bring it home.
他们跟着我去了音响店。我买了些扬声器电线。我们把它们带回家。
These guys are tenacious. If this is a scam, these guys are wasting a lot of time. It's getting harder to imagine it's a scam the longer they stick with it.
这些人真够执着的。如果这是一个骗局，这些人浪费的时间也太多了。他们坚持得越久，就越难想象这是一个骗局。
And I bring one of the speakers inside. And I plug it in. And it sounds, it just sounds fine. It doesn't sound one way or another. And I go out and I say, "It sounds good, I guess." And they've got it in your mind that it's going to just blow you away. And I think I even said something mildly, not critical, but just unimpressed, like, "The low end sounds a little mushy."
我把其中一个音箱拿进去。我插上电源。听起来，就是听起来很普通。没什么特别的。我走出来说，“我觉得听起来不错。”他们在你脑子里灌输它会让你惊艳的想法。我想我甚至说了一些轻微的，不算批评但不太感冒的话，比如，“低音听起来有点糊。”
And then they have this whole spiel, like, "If you just put in Monster wire, it'll take care of that." The Monster wire, and it's Monster wire. And I don't even know what Monster wire is, but that sounds good to me.
然后他们又有一套说辞，比如，“如果你接上Monster电线，就能解决这个问题。”Monster电线，就是Monster电线。我甚至不知道Monster电线是什么，但这听起来不错。
So now it comes to the negotiating part. And again, I'm thinking, "Heh. These guys don't know who they're dealing with." We go back and forth, and finally, it's like, "All right. $300." Because actually, that was the most I could take out on my cash station card.
现在到了讨价还价的环节。我心想，“呵。这些家伙根本不知道他们面对的是谁。”我们讨价还价，最后变成了，“好吧。300美元。”因为事实上，那是我能在自动取款机上取出来的最高金额。
Did you use that as a bargaining--
你把它当作筹码了吗——
Yes, yes. I probably said something like, "Well, you know, I can only get $300."
是的，是的。我大概说了一些像“嗯，你知道，我只能取出300美元”这样的话。
From that point on, they knew they were dealing with a high roller.
从那一刻起，他们就知道他们面对的是个大户。
They had no idea who they were messing with. So now I'm past thinking that it's a speaker scam. Now I'm on to thinking, well, if I do this, I'm somehow criminally liable. And I don't want to get busted. So I--
他们根本不知道自己在招惹谁。现在我不再认为这是个扬声器骗局了。现在我开始想，好吧，如果我这样做，我在某种程度上是有刑事责任的。我不想被抓。所以我——
Because you think they're stolen.
因为你以为它们是偷来的。
Well, these guys, if their story is true, they essentially stole them. So we're at the cash station. I've taken out the money. They're waiting in the car.
嗯，这些人，如果他们的故事是真的，他们基本上就是偷了它们。所以我们在自动取款机那儿。我已经取出了钱。他们在车里等。
I already have the speakers at my place, at my mom's place, that is. And I go to give them the money through the car window. And I've already written down the license plate. And I say, "If I go down, I'm taking you guys with me."
我已经在我的住处，也就是我妈家，放好了音箱。我从车窗把钱递给他们。我已经记下了车牌号。我说，“如果我要倒霉，我会拉着你们一起下水。”
The next thing that happens is I come home to my new speakers. I think, well, I'm going to find out just how much money I essentially made. I'm going to call the high-end audio store and ask them how much they sell the Pro Musica 555, whatever they are.
接下来发生的是我带着新音箱回到家。我想，好吧，我要看看我到底赚了多少钱。我要打电话给高端音响店，问他们Pro Musica 555或其他什么型号卖多少钱。
And I call the guy, I say, "How much do you sell, what do you know about the Pro Musica 555s?" He's like, "Hold on a second." He puts down the phone and comes back. He goes, "Did someone try to sell you those?" And I was like, "Yeah, someone did try to sell me those."
我给那个人打电话，我说，“你们卖多少钱，你知道Pro Musica 555吗？”他说，“等一下。”他放下电话又回来了。他问，“有人试图卖给你那个吗？”我说，“是的，有人试图卖给我那个。”
And he's like, "You should get a hold of the San Francisco Chronicle," blah blah blah, and he names a date. And it's this whole coast-to-coast, national, multimillion-dollar scam ring. Apparently, there's training, sort of like those pyramid marketing things. And apparently, it's everywhere. It started on the west coast, and it's moved all the way here.
他说，“你应该联系《旧金山纪事报》，”等等等等，他还报了一个日期。这是一个全国性、跨州、价值数百万美元的连锁骗局。显然，他们有培训，有点像那种金字塔营销。显然，它到处都是。它从西海岸开始，一直移到这里。
And I was like, "Awww." And I call information for the number of the place they said they work for that's stenciled on the side of their van, and that was on their shipping invoices and their, you know. And it's like, "No such number exists."
我心想，“喔。”我打电话查询他们说工作的公司号码，那个印在车身侧面、发票和所有东西上的号码。结果是，“该号码不存在。”
Fast forward a long time, a really long time, like 12 years maybe. And I'm in the parking lot of the fancy supermarket, Whole Foods, in Chicago. And I'm coming out, and it's like a gift from God. It's just so perfect.
时间快进很久，真的很久，可能12年吧。我在芝加哥全食超市的高端超市停车场里。我走出来，那简直是上天给的礼物。太完美了。
The exact same kind of van rolls up, the same kind of stencil, the same sort of guys inside. And out of everyone in this giant parking lot, they go, that's our guy. They come over to me, and they're like, "Dude! We got these speakers. We're the loading dock." It's this whole same spiel.
一模一样的面包车开了过来，同样的模板，里面坐着同样的那种家伙。在停车场的所有人里，他们认定，那就是我们的目标。他们向我走来，说：“哥们儿！我们有这些音箱。我们是装卸台的。”就是那一整套陈词滥调。
What you want here is basically, you want a Clint Eastwood, Charles Bronson line. You just want something totally cool and chilling that is going to totally stop him for some amount of time. And he's not going to expect it, and it's going to so perfectly cut through all his nonsense that he's just going to run in terror.
你在这里想要的是那种克林特·伊斯特伍德、查尔斯·布朗森式的台词。你只想说一些非常酷、非常让人不寒而栗的话，让对方愣住一会儿。他不会料到，而且它会如此完美地切断他所有的废话，让他惊恐地逃跑。
And I was also thinking, give him a chance. Don't just gun him down. Let him get a little head start. So I'm like, "I tell you what. I'm going to give you five minutes. And then I'm going to call the cops."
我还想，给他个机会。别直接开枪射杀他。让他跑一会儿。所以我说，“我告诉你。我给你五分钟时间。然后我会报警。”
And then he starts mocking me like nobody's business. He's like, "Oooh, tough guy. Think we're scared? Response time is 10 minutes. We'll be out of here," blah blah blah. And all the guys, it was like the monkey cage in the van. They're like, "Oo-oo-oo-ooh. Oh, scary. Oo-oo-oo-ooh."
然后他开始肆无忌惮地嘲笑我。他说，“噢，硬汉。以为我们怕了？响应时间是10分钟。我们那时早走了，”巴拉巴拉。车里的所有人都像猴子笼一样。他们说，“噢噢噢噢。噢，好怕怕。噢噢噢噢。”
And it's just, it's just so wrong. It's so embarrassing. And my retreat was so awful. In my mind, I'm slouching and hunchbacked and kind of worming my way to the pay phone. There's no quick calls.
太糟糕了。太尴尬了。我的退场太糟糕了。在我脑子里，我弯腰驼背，像虫子一样爬向公用电话。没有快速呼叫。
And that's the thing about Bronson. Bronson delivers his line and then shoots somebody or punches somebody. You delivered your line and then walked across a parking lot to make a pay phone call.
这就是布朗森的特点。布朗森说完台词就射杀某人或揍某人。你说了你的台词，然后穿过停车场去打公用电话。
Yeah, exactly. You want to try me, buddy? Pick up this phone.
是的，没错。你想试试吗，哥们儿？拿起这个电话。
Of course, the one bullet I have left in my gun at this point is I can go call. They can be arrested. Meanwhile, I'm looking out the window. And these guys are totally non-plussed. They're going, and they're soliciting other people. They're talking to other folks.
当然，我枪里剩下的那一发子弹是去报警。他们会被逮捕。同时，我向窗外望去。这些人根本不为所动。他们走了，还在兜售给其他人。他们正在和别人搭话。
I call 911 from the pay phone. And a dispatcher picks up, and he's like, "911 emergency." I'm like, "Yeah, there's these guys doing this speaker scam at the Whole Foods."
我从公用电话打给911。接线员接起电话，说：“911紧急服务。”我说，“是的，这些人正在全食超市搞扬声器诈骗。”
The dispatchers is like-- apparently she doesn't think this is an emergency-- and she's like, "What's the address where you're located at, sir?" And I have no idea. It's a shopping center. How do you know the address?
接线员——显然她不认为这是紧急情况——她说：“先生，你所在的地址在哪里？”我根本不知道。这是一个购物中心。你怎么知道地址？
And every question she asked me just betrays her thinking that this is not an emergency. This is not urgent. And we're not going to jump to it because you call and say these-- and I'm like, "Lady, you don't understand. A friend of mine fell for this scam once. I know what's going on."
她问的每一个问题都暴露了她觉得这不是紧急情况。这不紧急。我们不会因为你打电话说这些就立刻出警——我说，“女士，你不明白。我的一个朋友曾经上过这个骗局的当。我知道发生了什么。”
Shane Dubow and Alex Blumberg. Coming up, an entire nation which holds to the sucker mentality. Can you guess which nation I'm talking about? Can you guess? An answer in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
肖恩·杜博和亚历克斯·布隆伯格。接下来，是一个坚持冤大头心态的国家。你能猜到我说的是哪个国家吗？你能猜到吗？一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Suckers, in which we ask the question, is the world in fact a place where you either make someone else into a sucker, or you're the sucker. We've arrived at act three of our program, Act Three, Suckers in the Promised Land.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是：冤大头。在节目中，我们提出了这样一个问题：世界实际上是否是一个要么把别人变成冤大头，要么你就是冤大头的地方？我们来到了节目的第三幕，第三幕：应许之地的冤大头。
Regular listeners might remember not so long ago when reporter Adam Davidson and I did some stories from Israel. And while he and I were traveling around there, Adam told me to notice how often people use the word freier, which is the Yiddish word for sucker, the Israeli word for sucker. And I have to say, it happens all the time, because the idea of being a sucker is so much more powerful in Israel than it is here. Adam put together this primer on the huge place that freierism has in Israeli life, and how it explains things you didn't even know might need explaining.
经常收听的听众可能还记得不久前记者亚当·戴维森和我做了一些关于以色列的报道。当我和他在那里旅行时，亚当让我注意人们使用“freier”这个词的频率，这是意第绪语中“冤大头”的意思，是以色列语中“冤大头”的意思。我必须说，这种情况一直在发生，因为“成为冤大头”的想法在以色列比在这里要强大得多。亚当整理了这份入门读物，介绍了“freierism”（冤大头主义）在以色列生活中的巨大地位，以及它是如何解释那些你甚至不知道需要解释的事情的。
There is this amazing moment that was caught on film at the Camp David Peace Accords in 2000. President Clinton is leading then-Israeli Prime Minister Ehud Barak and Palestinian Authority Chairman Yasser Arafat into some log cabin for more negotiations. At the door, Arafat opens one arm to invite Barak to go in first. Barak stands there, impishly, and extends his own arm, telling Arafat to go in first.
2000年戴维营和平协议中，镜头捕捉到了一个惊人的时刻。克林顿总统引导当时的以色列总理埃胡德·巴拉克和巴勒斯坦权力机构主席亚西尔·阿拉法特进入一个小木屋进行进一步谈判。在门口，阿拉法特伸出一只手臂，邀请巴拉克先请。巴拉克俏皮地站在那里，伸出自己的手臂，让阿拉法特先请。
Things degenerated quickly. And you can actually see Barak and Arafat in a sort of fake wrestle, as Barak is trying to physically force Arafat to enter the door before he does. The thing seems irreconcilable until, through the door, you see President Clinton's long arms grab both men and pull them in.
事情迅速恶化。你可以看到巴拉克和阿拉法特在进行一种类似假摔的搏斗，巴拉克试图在体力上强迫阿拉法特先进入门内。事情看起来不可调和，直到透过门，你看到克林顿总统的长臂抓住两个人，把他们拉了进去。
I think some Americans saw this and thought it was a good sign. These two old enemies are now friendly enough for roughhousing. But for any Israeli watching, the message was clear.
我想一些美国人看到了这一幕，认为这是一个好兆头。这两个老敌人现在足够友好，可以打闹了。但对于任何观看节目的以色列人来说，信息很明确。
Barak was telling Arafat, I'm in control here. I decide who goes in and who doesn't. Nobody tells me when to go in a door. Put another way, I'm not your freier. I'm not your sucker.
巴拉克是在告诉阿拉法特，我在这里掌权。我决定谁先进去，谁不进去。没有人能告诉我什么时候进门。换句话说，我不是你的freier。我不是你的冤大头。
You constantly hear it, constantly. Don't be a freier.
你不断地听到这个词，不断地。不要做个freier。
This is Tom Segev, an Israeli journalist and historian.
这是汤姆·塞格夫，一位以色列记者和历史学家。
That is the worst thing for an Israeli to be, a freier, in his own eyes, and also in the eyes of other Israelis. So never, ever be generous. Be always on guard. Somebody is out there to take what is due to you.
对于以色列人来说，最糟糕的事情就是成为一名freier，在他们自己眼中，也在其他以色列人眼中。所以千万千万不要慷慨。时刻保持警惕。有人正准备拿走你应得的东西。
I think it would be impossible to understand Israelis without understanding the whole notion of freierism. It is at the heart of Israeli culture, affecting how people work, how they shop, how they vote, how they think about themselves and the people around them. Freierism is everywhere.
我认为如果不理解整个“freierism”的概念，就不可能理解以色列人。它是以色列文化的核心，影响着人们的工作方式、购物方式、投票方式，以及他们看待自己和周围人的方式。Freierism无处不在。
When I asked my cousin David if he'd ever been a freier, like any Israeli, he first said no. But when I pressed, he surprised me by recalling, in detail, an incident that happened years ago. He was in line to pay at a supermarket, and this woman came up and asked if she could jump in front of him because she only had a few items. He said sure. Then she wheeled over this cart filled with groceries. He realized that she had made him a freier.
当我问我的堂兄大卫他是否曾经做过freier时，像任何以色列人一样，他首先说没有。但当我追问时，他回忆起多年前发生的一件事，细节详尽，让我很吃惊。他在超市排队付钱，这个女人走过来问她能不能插在他前面，因为她只有几件商品。他说当然可以。然后她推过来一辆装满杂货的手推车。他意识到她让他成了一个freier。
He thinks about that woman every time he goes shopping, and he has never let anyone get in front of him since. This was years ago. Again, here's Tom Segev.
每次他去购物都会想到那个女人，从那以后他再也没让任何人插过队。那又是几年前的事了。再一次，这是汤姆·塞格夫。
Driving is a situation where the freier instinct really comes out. Driving in Israel is really hell because we will always be afraid that if you let the other guy get ahead, you will be the freier. Why would I let him go ahead of me if I can go ahead? Why should he go ahead of me?
开车是“freier”本能真正显露出来的情况。在以色列开车简直是地狱，因为我们总是担心如果你让别人先走，你就会成为freier。如果我能先走，为什么要让他走在我前面？为什么他要走在我前面？
From an Israeli point of view, Jews were suckers for 2,000 years in exile, constantly being tricked and persecuted. The whole idea of Israel was to create a place where Jews were in control, where Jews would never again be freiers. And even though Israel is now a powerful state, the fear of being taken advantage of hasn't gone away.
从以色列人的角度来看，犹太人在流亡的2000年里一直是被欺负的冤大头，不断地被欺骗和迫害。以色列整个存在的意义就是创造一个犹太人说了算的地方，一个犹太人永远不会再成为freier的地方。尽管以色列现在是一个强大的国家，但害怕被占便宜的恐惧并没有消失。
Israelis even fear that their own Jewish government makes them all freiers. Many Israelis say you're a freier if you pay your parking tickets, if you follow traffic laws. Even if you pay your taxes, you can be a freier.
以色列人甚至担心他们自己的犹太政府把他们都变成了freier。许多以色列人说，如果你交了停车罚单，如果你遵守交通规则，你就是个freier。甚至如果你纳税，你也可能成为一个freier。
I've seen people collecting what their dogs do on the sidewalk, even though nobody watches them. And that would probably be considered a freier, somebody who obeys the law, even though there's no policeman around.
我见过有人清理他们狗在人行道上的排泄物，即使没人看着他们。那很可能被认为是freier，一个即使没有警察在场也遵守法律的人。
Israel has an improvisational feel that America lacks. It's a place that hasn't quite settled yet. Every price can be negotiated. Every law is up for debate. Being a freier doesn't just mean getting taken advantage of, like being a sucker does here. It means you don't get how the whole system works.
以色列有一种美国所缺乏的即兴感。这是一个尚未完全安定下来的地方。每一个价格都可以协商。每一条法律都可以辩论。成为一名freier并不只是意味着像我们这里的冤大头那样被占便宜。它意味着你不了解整个系统是如何运作的。
In America, you're a sucker if you buy your stereo from some guy in a parking lot. But in Israel, it's the exact opposite. Anyone can buy a stereo in a store. You're the only one who knows that Moishe's cousin from Uzbekistan just got a shipment of off-brand stereos with Sony parts, and he's selling them out of his car in the central bus station for cheap. It's not that Israelis are obsessed with getting things cheap per se. It's just that if you don't, you're a freier.
在美国，如果你从停车场的一个人那里买音响，你就是冤大头。但在以色列，恰恰相反。任何人都能在店里买音响。只有你一个人知道莫伊舍的乌兹别克斯坦堂兄刚收到一批带索尼零件的杂牌音响，他正在中央巴士站把它们当白菜价卖。这并不是说以色列人本身沉迷于买便宜货。只是说如果你不这样做，你就是个freier。
I've always known that. And I've always noticed that when I get to Israel and start speaking Hebrew, my whole personality changes. I'm on guard. I'm ready to yell.
我一直都知道这一点。而且我一直注意到，当我到达以色列并开始说希伯来语时，我的整个人格就变了。我保持警惕。我准备大喊大叫。
But I don't think I really understood what freierism means until I was checking out of this hotel in Tel Aviv a few years ago. Because of some glitch, the hotel's computer put on my bill all these phone charges to places I've never called in my life, Poland, Uruguay, Sri Lanka. I went to the manager, and in seconds, he and I were screaming at each other.
但我认为我直到几年前在特拉维夫那家酒店退房时，才真正理解“freierism”意味着什么。因为某种故障，酒店的电脑把那些我一生中从未打过的电话费用都记在了我的账单上，波兰、乌拉圭、斯里兰卡。我去找经理，几秒钟内，我和他就互相咆哮起来。
I'm yelling at him, asking how he can charge for calls I never made. He's yelling back at me. This goes on for a while, until suddenly, I realize that he and I completely agree. He doesn't want me to pay the phone charges. I don't want to pay the phone charges. What we're really fighting over is who gets to say whether or not I pay the phone charges.
我对他大喊大叫，问他怎么能收取我没打过的电话费用。他对我大吼大叫。这持续了一会儿，直到突然间，我意识到我和他完全一致。他不想让我付那些电话费。我不想付那些电话费。我们真正争论的是谁有权决定我是否支付这些费用。
He's saying, "I'm the manager. You don't tell me you don't pay the bill. I tell you if you don't pay the bill." And I'm yelling back in Hebrew, "I'm the customer. You don't tell me if I pay the bill. I don't pay any bill that isn't correct." That's when I got it. We weren't fighting over money. We were fighting over who was the freier, him or me.
他说：“我是经理。你不能告诉我不付账单。我说了算。”我用希伯来语大声回敬：“我是顾客。你不能决定我是否付账单。我不付任何不正确的账单。”就在那时，我明白了。我们争论的不是钱。我们在争论谁才是freier，是他还是我。
(INTERVIEWER) ADAM DAVIDSON Have you been a freier recently?
（采访者）亚当·戴维森：你最近做过freier吗？
Probably.
大概做过吧。
Again, here's Tom Segev.
再一次，这是汤姆·塞格夫。
We are all freiers. We are a nation of freiers actually. We are a nation of freiers. And that's one of the childhood diseases which we have yet to overcome.
我们都是freier。我们实际上是一个freier的民族。我们是一个freier的民族。这是我们尚未克服的儿童疾病之一。
What do you mean, you're a nation of freiers?
你说的“你们是一个freier的民族”是什么意思？
I can tell you something on a more serious and on a more political level. I think that the Israeli left, the Israeli peace camp feels very much like being the freier these days. Because we have been advocating peace with the Palestinians, we are advocating compromises with the Palestinians. Very often, we have done that sitting in cafes which, hours later, have been blown up by Palestinian terrorists. So I think that many of us feel that Palestinian terrorism has made us, people of the Israeli peace camp, freiers.
我可以从更严肃、更政治的层面上告诉你一些事情。我认为以色列左派、以色列和平阵营现在感觉非常像个freier。因为我们一直主张与巴勒斯坦人和平共处，我们主张与巴勒斯坦人妥协。我们经常在咖啡馆里这样做，而几个小时后，这些咖啡馆就被巴勒斯坦恐怖分子炸毁了。所以我认为我们很多人觉得巴勒斯坦恐怖主义把我们这些以色列和平阵营的人变成了freier。
In fact, the whole peace process is infected with the idea of freierism. Both sides know what the final outcome is going to be, a Palestinian state next to Israel, Israel giving up some settlements in the West Bank and Gaza. But each side has to play its hand to see that it gets the absolute best deal, that they aren't taken for freiers. And of course, any peace depends on both sides trusting each other. And trusting, everyone knows, is the mark of a true freier.
事实上，整个和平进程都感染了“freierism”的想法。双方都知道最终结果是什么，巴勒斯坦国毗邻以色列，以色列放弃西岸和加沙的一些定居点。但每一方都必须打好自己的牌，以确保得到最好的交易，确保他们不会被当作freier。当然，任何和平都取决于双方互相信任。而大家都知道，信任是真正freier的标志。
Adam Davidson in Los Angeles.
亚当·戴维森在洛杉矶。
We now move on to Act Four, Mother Sucker. We have this story about the meaning of parenthood and the prevalence of being made a sucker from Heather O'Neill.
现在进入第四幕，母爱冤大头。我们有一个关于为人父母的意义以及被当做冤大头的普遍性的故事，来自希瑟·奥尼尔。
When I was 18 years old, I moved out of my dad's house with a suitcase and headed downtown. And there was nothing anyone could do about it. I grew up in the smallest apartment in the world, with my dad yelling all the time. My two sisters and I all slept in a tiny room with two bunk beds and a cardboard box of clothing that we all shared. After an atrocious childhood, I was delighted to be a grown-up.
我18岁那年，带着一个手提箱搬出了我爸爸的家，去了市中心。没人能阻止我。我在世界上最小的公寓里长大，我爸爸总是大喊大叫。我和两个妹妹睡在一个装有两个双层床的狭小房间里，还有一个我们共用的装衣服的纸箱。在经历了惨痛的童年之后，我很高兴成为一个成年人。
My friend, Ben, and I got an apartment. You turned on the oven at 3:00 in the afternoon if you wanted it to be hot by suppertime. We never locked the door. We'd lost all the keys.
我的朋友本和我租了一套公寓。如果你想在晚饭时吃到热乎的，你得在下午3点打开烤箱。我们从不锁门。我们把钥匙全弄丢了。
After living there peacefully for a couple of months, one night, Ben brought home Jimmy. Jimmy was a 16-year-old boy that he had found at the Electric Bumbum, a club down the street. Ben said that Jimmy had been walking around the bar, asking all the women for a hug. He was carrying a little leather bag that looked like a doctor's kit that he kept his underwear in. He had just escaped from Shawbridge, a juvenile detention center that was north of the city. He had tried to go home, but his mother had moved without telling him her new address.
在那里平静地生活了几个月后，一天晚上，本带回了吉米。吉米是一个16岁的男孩，他在街头的Electric Bumbum俱乐部发现的。本说吉米一直在酒吧里走来走去，向所有的女性求抱抱。他随身带着一个看起来像医生工具包的小皮包，用来装内裤。他刚从城北的肖布里奇少年拘留中心逃出来。他曾试着回家，但他妈妈搬家了，没告诉他新地址。
I could see why Ben had decided to help him out. Jimmy looked like the Little Prince. He had the biggest eyes on the planet. And he always had a surprised expression on his face. He had blond hair that was sticking straight up, and he was small for his age. He was 16, but he looked about 11 or 12. On his pale bicep, he had a homemade tattoo that said Lisa. Lisa was a half-sister he had only met once, five years before.
我能看出本为什么决定帮助他。吉米看起来像《小王子》。他有世界上最大的眼睛。他脸上总是带着惊讶的表情。他留着竖起来的金色头发，而且他长得显小。他16岁了，但看起来像11或12岁。在他苍白的二头肌上，有一个自制的刺青写着“丽莎”。丽莎是他五年前只见过一次的同父异母妹妹。
He also acted like a little kid. That first night when Ben brought him into the living room, I handed him this transparent balloon with white stars on it, and Jimmy went on and on about how it was the most beautiful thing anyone had ever given him. I liked that.
他也像个小孩子一样行事。本第一次把他带进客厅那天晚上，我给了他这个带白色星星的透明气球，吉米不停地说这是别人送给他的最美丽的东西。我喜欢这一点。
Jimmy needed a place to stay for the night. Ben said he could sleep on the couch. So Jimmy took off his pants and folded them on the coffee table. He was wearing Spider-Man underwear.
吉米需要一个地方过夜。本说他可以睡沙发。于是吉米脱下裤子，叠在咖啡桌上。他穿着蜘蛛侠的内裤。
"Heather, could you tuck me in?" he asked. I thought he was joking, seeing as he was 16, and I was 18. But he just lay there, perfectly still and straight, waiting for the blankets to be pulled up to his chin.
“希瑟，你能帮我掖掖被子吗？”他问。我以为他在开玩笑，毕竟他16岁，我18岁。但他只是躺在那里，一动不动，笔直地等待着被子被拉到下巴。
So I did it. I tucked him in. What else could I do? It was silly, but it also made me feel warm inside. Suddenly, I felt very mature.
所以我照做了。我帮他掖好了被子。我还能做什么呢？这很傻，但也让我心里感到温暖。突然间，我觉得自己非常成熟。
When I fantasized about having a kid, it was never about being in a relationship or being pregnant. I always imagined finding a baby in a garbage can and raising it as my own. I would do everything for that little baby and never give it up.
当我幻想有孩子时，从没想过要谈恋爱或怀孕。我总是幻想在垃圾桶里捡到一个婴儿，然后把它抚养长大。我会为那个小宝贝做任何事，绝不放弃。
When I was still very little, my mother told me that she was moving to New Orleans. She said she had never been able to do fun things because she had had me when she was only 19. She said if she stayed and looked after me, she would only depress me. She said really, she was doing me a favor. She left her apartment and walked down the street with her things, saying that she was going to the airport. I found out years later that she had just moved across town.
我还是个小孩子时，我妈妈告诉我她要搬去新奥尔良。她说她从来没能做过有趣的事情，因为她在19岁时就有了我。她说如果她留下来照顾我，她只会让我感到沮丧。她说说实话，她是在帮我。她离开了公寓，带着行李走在街上，说她要赶飞机。几年后我才知道，她只是搬到了城对过。
The next morning, when I sat on the coffee table and asked Jimmy where he was going to go, he begged me to let him stay. I told him I didn't want to get in trouble with the law. And besides, we were broke.
第二天早上，当我坐在咖啡桌上问吉米要到哪里去时，他恳求我让他留下。我告诉他我不想惹法律麻烦。而且，我们身无分文。
"You guys could be my foster parents," he pleaded. Jimmy said that once a kid in foster care is 16, he can be eligible for independent living. As long as you got any adult to come and say they wanted you to live with them, it would be OK. He said he was very envious of his friend, Juan, who had talked a women who worked at his school's cafeteria into being his foster mom.
“你们可以做我的寄养父母，”他恳求道。吉米说，一旦寄养家庭的孩子到了16岁，就有资格独立生活。只要有任何成年人站出来说他们希望你和他们住在一起，那就没问题。他说他很羡慕他的朋友胡安，他曾说服学校食堂的一位女士做了他的寄养妈妈。
We had to go clear across town to visit Jimmy's social worker. It was a bleak kind of neighborhood. There seemed to be train tracks everywhere and laundry lines with no clothes on them.
我们不得不横穿全城去见吉米的社工。那是一个阴郁的街区。到处都是火车轨道和上面没有衣服的晾衣绳。
There were two identical buildings next to each other at the end of a street. One of the buildings had all its windows broken. The other one was the Office for Child Welfare.
街尽头有两栋一模一样的建筑。其中一栋的窗户全破了。另一栋是儿童福利办公室。
Before we walked into the building, I opened my mouth, and Ben squirted some breath spray in. The social worker stared at us. "Why do you want to be Jimmy's foster parents?" she asked. "I like to read books," I said. It was all I could think of to say. I'd always imagined that kids who were read to must be much smarter than me.
我们走进大楼之前，我张开嘴，本喷了一些口喷剂。社工盯着我们。“你们为什么要成为吉米的寄养父母？”她问。“我喜欢读书，”我说。我能想到的只有这个。我一直觉得读书的孩子一定比我聪明得多。
I was just quiet after that, but she didn't seem to care how we were planning to raise Jimmy. In fact, the only thing she wanted from us was proof that we were 18. Nothing else seemed to matter. Taking the long subway ride out there seemed to show enough initiative on our parts.
那之后我一直很安静，但她似乎不在乎我们打算怎么抚养吉米。事实上，她唯一想要的是我们已经18岁的证明。其他什么都不重要。搭乘那么长时间的地铁去那里似乎足以显示我们的主动性。
She gave us an address of a school that would accept Jimmy, and then she gave us a roll of green children's bus tickets so that he could get there each day. Then she gave us some forms to fill out, which she apologized profusely for. She explained it was a drag, but it had to be done for accounting, so that we could get money. "If you have any problems, don't call me. Call the front desk first," she said, waving goodbye.
她给了我们一所接收吉米的学校的地址，然后给了我们一卷绿色儿童公交票，这样他每天就能去学校了。然后她给了我们一些表格要填，她为此反复道歉。她解释说这很烦人，但为了会计必须完成，这样我们才能拿到钱。“如果有什么问题，别打给我。先打给前台，”她一边挥手告别一边说。
We were given a $100 check to buy him things that he needed. It seemed like a lot of money to me. I took him out shopping for school supplies. We got a large purse with a rainbow on it that he could use to keep his school books in. I also bought him an umbrella and a pair of snow pants.
我们收到了一张100美元的支票，用来给他买需要的东西。对我来说那看起来是一大笔钱。我带他去买学校用品。我们买了一个带彩虹的大钱包，他可以用来装课本。我还给他买了一把伞和一条雪裤。
Then Jimmy and I saw this dress shirt with pink birds on it that looked like it would fit either of us perfectly. We both grabbed for it. I shoved him right into a plastic container of shoes. "Child abuse," he screamed. On the subway back home, he wouldn't stop bugging me, so I bit him on the ear. My dad used to always do that to me with his broken tooth. Pretty soon after Jimmy moved in, things started to go missing around the apartment. If we left a handful of change on the bathroom sink, it would disappear. So would Ben's cigarettes. The radio on the kitchen table was suddenly not there one day, but Jimmy denied that he had taken anything. In my heart, of course, I couldn't really believe him. But it wasn't like he was taking anything I couldn't live without.
然后吉米和我看到这件带粉色鸟儿的礼服衬衫，看起来穿在我们身上都很合适。我们同时伸手去抢。我把他推进了一个塑料鞋盒。“虐待儿童，”他尖叫道。在回家的地铁上，他不停地烦我，所以我咬了他的耳朵。我爸爸以前总用他那颗坏牙对我那样。吉米搬进来没多久，公寓里的东西开始丢了。如果我们把一把零钱留在浴室台子上，它就会消失。本的香烟也是。厨房桌子上的收音机突然有一天不见了，但吉米否认拿过任何东西。在我内心深处，我当然无法真正相信他。但也不是说他拿走了什么我活不下去的东西。
Jimmy had to go to a remedial high school. It wasn't long before I was being called in to talk to his teacher. She said that he kept taking his shirt off in class. She said he had 100 spelling mistakes and never did his homework. And she said that Jimmy had been missing tons of school.
吉米必须去一所补习高中。没过多久我就被叫去和他的老师谈话。她说他一直在课堂上脱衬衫。她说他有100个拼写错误，从不做家庭作业。而且她说吉米已经旷了很多课。
"Why haven't you been going to school?" I asked him. "What have you been doing with your days?" "I don't know," he said.
“你为什么不去学校？”我问他。“这些天你在做什么？”“我不知道，”他说。
More things vanished from the apartment, records, books, cutlery. One afternoon, while sitting outside on the stoop, I noticed that the next door neighbor was wearing Ben's hat. I asked him where he got it. And the neighbor said, "That blond kid who lives with you sold it to me."
更多东西从公寓消失了，唱片、书籍、餐具。一天下午，坐在门口的台阶上，我注意到隔壁邻居戴着本的帽子。我问他从哪儿弄来的。邻居说，“和你住在一起的那个金发小子卖给我的。”
Then while cleaning, I found under Jimmy's blanket a sweat sock, stuffed full, like a Christmas stocking. There was my gold chain with a pink rose. He stole a tiny porcelain southern belle that an ex-boyfriend had given to me. There was even a magnet from the fridge in the shape of a cough syrup bottle with a 1-800 number on it. When I brought it up, Jimmy said they were just souvenirs.
后来，在打扫卫生时，我在吉米的毯子下发现了一只装得满满的汗袜，就像圣诞长袜一样。里面有我那条带粉红玫瑰的金链子。他偷了一个前男友送给我的小瓷偶南方佳人。甚至还有一个冰箱磁铁，形状像是一个写着1-800号码的止咳糖浆瓶。当我提起这件事时，吉米说这些只是纪念品。
I genuinely liked Jimmy, but I was slowly realizing that nobody else did. When we had friends over, he would moonwalk from one person to the next offering to massage their faces. He'd sit right next to them and ask, "If you could be any animal, what would it be? I'd be an otter because it's original and I like waterslides."
我真心喜欢吉米，但我慢慢意识到没别人喜欢他。当朋友们来访时，他会从一个人走到另一个人，提议给他们按摩脸部。他会坐在他们身边问，“如果你能成为任何动物，你会成为哪种？我会成为水獭，因为这很有创意，而且我喜欢水滑梯。”
Also, he'd ask for everything. "Oh, that's a beautiful watch," he'd say. "Can I have it? Can I have your necklace? Please, I'll wear it every day."
而且，他会索要一切。“哦，那是个漂亮的手表，”他会说。“我能要吗？我能要你的项链吗？拜托，我会每天戴着的。”
"Why do you let that little mooch live here?" people would ask. "He's so annoying. He's so squirrelly." I defended Jimmy, saying that he was just going through a phase. He was only a kid. It wasn't his fault that he wasn't mature. I thought he was really showing signs of an artistic temperament.
“你为什么要让那个小蹭吃蹭喝的住这儿？”人们会问。“他太烦人了。他像只松鼠一样。”我为吉米辩护，说他只是经历一个阶段。他还是个孩子。他不够成熟不是他的错。我认为他真的表现出艺术气质的迹象。
After all, Rimbaud was a runaway too. If we had found Rimbaud at the Electric Bumbum, I'm sure everyone would also think he was a pretentious teenager, what with his ranting and his poetry. Rimbaud might also knock over the lamp practicing his disco moves and wear glasses with the lenses popped out in an attempt to express himself.
毕竟，兰波也是个离家出走者。如果我们能在Electric Bumbum找到兰波，我相信大家也会觉得他是个做作的青少年，整天在那儿狂吠和写诗。兰波练习迪斯科舞步时也可能会打翻灯，并且戴着没有镜片的眼镜来表达自我。
We had had him six months, and still no money had come. Ben asked Jimmy to stop at the social worker and find out where the checks were. Jimmy said that he'd just been there, and that there was a paperwork problem, and we'd be getting the money soon.
我们养他六个月了，还是没收到钱。本让吉米去找社工看看支票在哪儿。吉米说他刚去过，有文书工作问题，我们很快就会拿到钱。
Jimmy, our growing boy, was starting to develop a little potbelly from eating all the food in the house, while at the same time, Ben and I were starting to lose weight. Ben complained all the time about how there was never any food in the fridge. Jimmy would eat up every last thing. One time, we came home, and Jimmy was sitting on the couch, watching TV, with a big pot of spaghetti sauce on his lap. Ben started putting him on a scale to make sure he wasn't gaining weight.
吉米，我们那个正在长身体的孩子，因为吃光了家里所有的食物，开始长出一点小肚子，而与此同时，本和我开始消瘦。本总是在抱怨冰箱里从来没有食物。吉米会把最后一点东西吃光。有一次，我们回到家，吉米坐在沙发上看电视，腿上放着一大锅意大利面酱。本开始让他上秤，以确保他没有增加体重。
At this point, Jimmy wasn't going to school at all. Ben started complaining that he needed to have some sort of activity, other than "eating all our food and following me around all day." "You should try to do something that involves ambition," Ben told him. "Don't you even have a hobby?"
此时，吉米根本不去学校。本开始抱怨说他需要做些活动，而不是“吃光我们的食物，整天跟着我”。“你应该尝试做点有志向的事情，”本告诉他。“你难道连个爱好都没有吗？”
He decided Jimmy had to get out of the house on his own for at least an hour on the weekends. Jimmy would just stand on the balcony, shivering. He'd get down on his knees and call for me through the mail slot. I told Ben that he was pushing Jimmy too hard. When the hour was up, I would rush to unlock the door and let Jimmy back in.
他决定吉米周末必须至少有一个小时独自待在户外。吉米就站在阳台上颤抖。他跪在地上，通过邮件槽叫我。我告诉本他逼吉米太紧了。那一个小时结束后，我会冲去开门让吉米进来。
Then one day, Ben had had enough. Jimmy walked in the kitchen wearing Ben's shoes, except they were painted white and had little blue stars on them. "How do you like my dancing shoes?" he asked. "Those are my shoes!" Ben screamed. "No, you never had a pair of white shoes with blue stars on them," said Jimmy. "I would have noticed."
后来有一天，本忍无可忍了。吉米走进厨房，穿着本的鞋子，只不过它们被涂成了白色，上面还有小蓝星星。“你觉得我的舞鞋怎么样？”他问。“那是我的鞋！”本尖叫道。“不，你从来没穿过那种带蓝星星的白鞋，”吉米说。“我会注意到的。”
Ben told Jimmy he had gone too far. "I'm calling your social worker in the morning. I don't know how to deal with a kleptomaniac teenager."
本告诉吉米他太过分了。“我明天早上就打给你社工。我不知道怎么处理一个盗窃癖的青少年。”
The thought of kicking Jimmy out made me feel rotten inside. It made me feel like a degenerate or a criminal. I couldn't stand the thought of him having no place to go. I don't know if that means I'm a sucker or that I just don't care if I'm a sucker.
一想到要把吉米赶走就让我内心感到烂透了。这让我觉得自己像个堕落者或罪犯。我无法忍受他无处可去。我不知道这意味着我是个冤大头，还是我根本不在乎自己是不是冤大头。
The next morning, Jimmy was gone anyway, along with a houseload of souvenirs. He didn't even say goodbye. I thought that I had been such a good mother too. I couldn't believe he'd want to run away.
第二天早上，吉米还是走了，带走了一整屋的纪念品。他甚至没说再见。我还以为我一直是个这么好的母亲呢。我简直不敢相信他会想离家出走。
When Ben woke up, he found that the envelope with his $150 that he had spent 40 hours working for was gone. The rent was due, and we were flat broke. Ben called the social worker to ask about the checks. She said that they had all been given to Jimmy. Jimmy had just been cashing them and spending the money himself.
本醒来时发现他辛苦工作40小时赚来的150美元的信封不见了。房租到期了，我们身无分文。本打电话给社工询问支票的事。她说它们全都给吉米了。吉米一直在兑现它们，并自己花掉了钱。
Ben felt like Jimmy had totally taken us for fools. I felt like, well, what do you expect? Now, years later, I have a seven-year-old daughter, and I've come to realize that to be a parent is to be a sucker. You get suckered into being an unappreciated servant who works for free. You get suckered into giving up your privacy. You're suckered into giving up movies and holidays to pay for ballet lessons, and plastic alien babies, and enough bubble gum to stretch to the moon.
本觉得吉米把我们彻底当成了傻子。我觉得，嗯，你还指望什么？现在，几年后，我有一个七岁的女儿，我开始意识到为人父母就是做一个冤大头。你被诱骗成为一个不被赏识的、免费工作的仆人。你被诱骗放弃隐私。你被诱骗放弃电影和假日，去支付芭蕾课、塑料外星人玩具和足以拉到月球的泡泡糖的费用。
And kids will treat you like a sucker. They'll lie right to your face. My daughter tries to convince me before leaving to school in the morning that she doesn't have lip gloss on even though her lips are glistening like candy apples.
而且孩子会把你当成冤大头。他们会对着你的脸撒谎。我女儿每天早上出门前都试图说服我她没擦唇彩，尽管她的嘴唇像糖苹果一样发亮。
And what makes being a parent the ultimate sucker is that not only are you being taken for a sucker, but you actually like it. I lie and connive and manipulate on her behalf all the time, and I do it with pleasure. The other day, I sewed a little pocket inside her jacket so that she could sneak her cards to school after they were banned. "Watch out for the lunch monitors," I tell her. "They're on a power trip." I write her notes saying, "Please let my daughter go to the bathroom whenever she wants. She has serious stomach problems."
而且，成为父母之所以是终极的冤大头，是因为你不仅被当成了冤大头，而且你实际上很喜欢这样。我一直为她撒谎、谋划、操纵，并且乐此不疲。前几天，我给她的夹克缝了一个小口袋，好让她在卡片被禁止后能把它们偷偷带到学校。“小心午餐监察员，”我告诉她。“他们权力欲很强。”我写字条给她说，“请让我的女儿随时去厕所。她有严重的胃病。”
And I only wish I could do more. I wish I could sit beside her during her math tests and whisper her the answers. I wish I could cup her ears with my palms when the teacher starts yelling at her for not listening. I wish I could stand with her in the schoolyard at lunchtime and give her the sandwich I packed for work because she decided to feed hers to the birds.
而且我只希望我能做得更多。我希望能在数学考试时坐在她身边，悄悄告诉她答案。我希望在老师开始对她大喊大叫时，用手掌捂住她的耳朵。我希望能在午饭时间站在操场上，把打包带去工作的三明治给她，因为她决定把自己的那份喂给鸟儿。
Heather O'Neill is a poet and novelist.
希瑟·奥尼尔是一位诗人和小说家。
This is the last program that we have the pleasure of working with producer-in-training Chris Neary. He has had many ideas on how to structure and rework stories that have made our show better, and we are the worse for him going. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
这是我们有幸与制作实习生克里斯·尼里共事的最后一个节目。他在如何构建和重塑故事方面有很多想法，让我们的节目变得更好，而失去他则是我们的损失。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助商致谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who's got an answer for anything we say about him here.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，对于我们在这里说他的任何话，他都有回应。
Oo-oo-oo-ooh. Oh, scary. Oo-oo-oo-ooh.
噢噢噢噢。噢，好怕怕。噢噢噢噢。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。